ladies and gentlemen I am pleased to be
here today as we announce this
integration one that reinforces
Switzerland as a leading Global
Financial Center
bringing UBS and Credit Suisse together
will build on the best skills available
in the Swiss financial center and
enhance the combined organization's
ability to serve our clients and deepen
Our Best in Class capabilities
in realizing the enormous opportunities
the steel represents we are also aware
of the need to support the broader Swiss
economy and our clients at a time when
macroeconomic uncertainty makes business
conditions challenging and unpredictable
I am grateful for the strong support of
the Swiss Federal Council the Federal
Department of Finance finma and the
Swiss National Bank who initiated the
discussions
we have agreed a framework of support
that the Swiss Regulators which ensures
a successful integration in the best
interests of Switzerland and protects
our shareholders I would like to thank
the authorities for their close
collaboration during this progress
process and will continue to work with
them as the integration processes
progresses
the combination of the two Banks further
strengthens ubs's position as a leading
Global wealth manager with more than 5
trillion US dollars in total invested
assets operating in the most attractive
growth markets
it will also reinforce ubs's position as
the leading Universal Bank in
Switzerland and further extend our
position as the most important Swiss
global bank
having been Chief Financial Officer
during the last Global financial crisis
and well aware of the importance of a
solid balance sheet especially in
challenging Times Like These a new UBS
will remain Rock Solid this transaction
confirms and augments our strategy of
growing our Capital light businesses let
me be very specific on this UBS intends
to downsize credit suisse's Investment
Banking business and align it with our
conservative risk culture
it is intended that the combined
Investment Banking businesses will over
time account for no more than 25 of the
group's risk-weighted assets
ubs's strength and our familiarity with
Credit Suisse is business puts us in a
unique position to execute this
integration efficiently and effectively
with Swiss and international clients
best interest in mind
Ralph hammers will be the group CEO of
the combined entity and I will continue
in my role as chairman
this transaction
supports Financial stability in
Switzerland and creates significant
sustainable value for UBS shareholders
combining the best of Credit Suisse with
our strategy and culture will help these
businesses flourish we will provide
updates as the integration progresses in
the meantime we will focus on serving
our clients at both institutions I am
pleased that this transaction will bring
the long desired stability for the
Credit Suisse client base
we're well aware that in the coming
weeks and months will be difficult for
many especially for the employees let me
reassure you that we will do our utmost
to keep this time of uncertainty as
short as possible
let me close by thanking all parties
involved for the incredibly hard work
and excellent collaboration over the
past days at the same time I would like
to extend a very warm welcome to all our
new clients and colleagues across the
world